Mackie is wacky because he insults his
own workers John Mackey wrote the CEO of
Whole Foods wrote about that in the Wall
Street Journal opposing health care
reform and wanted to leave it to the
market we're with the United Food and
Commercial Workers Union Local 400 and
we're out here basically advertising to
the consumers of Whole Foods this stance
that the CEO of Whole Foods has taken
against health care reform in the
country
my name is a honey brown I'm a whole
body team leader I work here at P Street
and I've been with the company
approximately six years since 2003 yes
six years I feel the protesters are
entitled to their opinion I was sort of
surprised by the reaction because i
think i have good health care John
Mackey's personal preference is to not
give a [ __ ] about his latino based work
is you know you know that's pretty much
what it is this is the best health care
I've ever had and what I like about is I
have the freedom that goes pretty much
whatever doctor I want to go to hope
with Marcus actually gives you money
towards a deductible the whole foods
health care system is a combination of a
high deductible plan where we have a
deductible of about twenty-five hundred
dollars combined with what we call
personal wellness account and the money
goes on to a card it's like a charge
card and depending on how many service
hours you have that sort of determines
how much goes on to your wellness card
annually our team members are spending
their their dollars because the money is
transferred to them and it's in their
accounts so when they go out and have to
purchase health care since the first
twenty five hundred dollars is coming
out of their personal wellness accounts
they have a different attitude towards
it you can actually sort of manager your
account you what I mean it makes you
sort of think about how are you spending
what's on your car the general consensus
is that I've got from talking to people
is that people look pretty happy the
plan that's offered through whole foods
market works for me my experience with
Whole Foods health care is good I've had
nothing but kind of good relations with
my my health benefits from home phase
certainly those employees have a right
to their opinion and I respect that and
also if they don't know any other way
then they don't know if there's anything
better out there prior to come in the
whole foods market I work for another
company for 10 years so I have the two
programs to
compare I love it I love it so much I
carry my husband and my children all of
us on it that's how good it is I would
say that if I had the opportunity to
look at some of the plans that are
provided to union members in a retail
grocery industry doing the same work
that they're doing I'm pretty confident
that those those health care plans would
would exceed what they're getting it
opens but they they're ignorant of that
because their employer wouldn't allow
them to have a choice every three years
we vote on what is in our health care
package one of the things about whole
foods market is like everybody is
empowered just to get the conversation
going since we're the ones that are
ultimately paying for it what do we want
in our package you know this isn't
necessarily centered on Whole Foods of
their employees it's more of a
conversation of in conjunction with what
we're going through as a country right
now our system costs less money than
most other companies pay and it provides
high value that our team members like
and I don't think we're we're arguing it
as the complete solution to every single
problem that exists out there my
position is that the reforms that I
advocated in that and the Wall Street
Journal op-ed would help tens of
millions of people have better health
care and health insurance
I think this is really ridiculous I hope
nobody here boycotts whole foods because
these people don't agree with what the
owner agrees with thank you
you